you to bread not mentioned in the main
video is YouTube's second source of
income that avoids the whole advertiser
auction by getting viewers to pay
monthly to hide the ads and get access
to exclusive content YouTube keeps the
exact split of revenue a secret only
saying that creators get a majority but
whatever that percent is that portion of
the money collected from subscribers is
divided among all creators based on what
percent of total time on YouTube their
videos are watched doing a very ballpark
estimate channels with short videos
might get around 5% additional revenue
from red and channels with really long
videos that our watch might get 40 to 50
percent more it's worth noting that per
view a Youtube subscriber is worth more
to both YouTube and creators not just in
dollars but also in stability their
monthly payments are predictable unlike
the ad auctions so it shouldn't be a
surprise if YouTube continues to try to
turn more subscribers and country's red